I'm sure Yuki said the feminists kind of
hate you they hate me okay a why do they
hate you and then B can you be both can
you be a career woman
and a submissive housewife mom is it
possibly both and is that what the
feminists hate about you is that you're
like I just would rather be a housewife
and listen to my husband I don't want to
have a career anymore like give us that
perspective yeah so you know I was very
much involved in the feminist movement I
was at the marches all that stuff oh
straight up full-on March of it yeah
vagina hat on yeah the whole deal yes
yes send me one of those hats by the way
I know I don't know did you literally
burn a hat yeah yeah wow sorry for I
guess I'm not sorry but no you're not
clearly not sorry yeah okay um but you
were full-on feminine yeah and I said so
I speak out against feminism and what
it's done to women and so that that's
the real issue is that feminism by I
guess the
if you look at like the book right like
if you read it it sounds great women's
equality all that stuff who doesn't want
that right I I'd like to see still keep
voting and things of that nature but
in practice you're seeing a lot of
missandra you're seeing a lot of hatred
towards men you're seeing a lot of well
I don't have to have accountability for
my actions but men still have to be
accountable for their actions and you
know it and feminism is also a spectrum
right so you have the the ones that
shave their heads I also did that
um and like the ones that are like The
Fringe right and then you have beautiful
only fans models and I'm not saying
that's that's you particularly but you
have a spectrum of feminism and I think
a lot of times too it's so baked into
the society into our culture that you
don't even know that you're saying a
feminist I ideology you don't even know
that you're spewing it out but you are
okay um and so like get that bag make
that money like all of those I'm a boss
[ __ ] I'm a bad [ __ ] that whole thing
is that that's a that's a form of
feminism right what is the worst I need
you to be your super real Right male
feminist okay that I was gonna ask about
the worst or the worst of the worst when
it comes to feminism male feminists what
is that the men who pretend to be a
menace and
are
actually they hate women they they
oppress women and so it's like the
opposite of what you would do I have
zero clue what you're talking about
right now what do you mean they hate
women but they're male feminists yeah
but they pretend to care okay it's a
similar thing to the whole woke ideology
yeah you know this person says I'm a
racist right but they have
they've said racist things does that
does that make sense or no okay so give
us an example of these male feminists
uh
[Music]
uh okay a male feminist would say your
body your choice right and then hook up
with someone and then
you know tell them not get an abortion
yeah yeah just it's there's different
there's different forms of it but what
what like it sounds like there's almost
indoctrination yeah no it is meaning
childhood yes okay what walk us through
what the indoctrination Pro it's not
like a formal process welcome to women's
feminism class but what is the
indoctrination process it's the movies
it's the TV shows it's
um
putting men to be like these Dopey
characters like Family Guy right like oh
the woman knows everything and she is
the leader of the house and the man is
an idiot and just doping around like oh
I don't know what to do I have to rely
on my wife like think about any 90
seconds I can't cook whatever's gonna
starve to death yeah yeah if my wife
isn't home yeah basically well it's just
this you know idea that gets painted and
everything and then you know you have
these superheroes that these female
superheroes I can beat every man and
they can take on like multiple you know
multiple villains at the same time
realistically women are weaker like we
are physically weaker than men I don't
think that I could beat up uh six foot
five you know
NFL player maybe Ruslan has a better
chance or if you have a better chance do
you think you could take Ruslan in a
fight no I think you should guys should
figure it out right
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire saucecast click right
here
[Music]